Générique
...
-Bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table !",
l'émission où on parle cuisine,
alimentation, agriculture,
mais aussi politique.
Nous recevons
Emmanuel Taché de La Pagerie,
merci d'être venu.
-Bonjour.
-Avec moi,
pour l'émission,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour à vous.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes député
RN des Bouches-du-Rhône,
élu depuis juin 2022.
Vous êtes entré
au RN dix ans plus tôt,
en 2012,
mais votre carrière politique
commence dès 95,
sous les couleurs du RPR,
puis de l'UMP.
Vous avez alors 20 ans.
Assistant parlementaire,
vous êtes conseiller politique
de Palaiseau jusqu'en 2001
et l'un des fondateurs
de l'association pour
les droits LGBT, GayLib.
Entre 2018 et 2021,
vous êtes chargé
de la communication au groupe
des eurodéputés RN au Parlement
européen.
Ardent défenseur de la corrida,
dans un magazine
de la rédaction de LCP,
vous allez au bout
de vos convictions...
-Oui. Ca dépote.
De la gardiane,
autrement dit,
de la daube de taureau.
Et en dessert,
un tiramisu...
-Par la suite,
en janvier, la star,
c'est la galette.
On vous offre la dégustation
et il y en aura
pour tous les goûts.
-Les Français,
de plus en plus fans de riz.
Il n'y a pas
que le riz basmati.
Mais aussi du grain français,
cultivé en Camargue.
Reportage à suivre.
-Allez, on passe
à table, tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Emmanuel Taché de La Pagerie,
quel parcours,
pour vous,
l'enfant du 93,
avec votre silhouette
de toréador,
vous vous êtes fait une place
au soleil d'Arles, ville de feria,
où vous avez pris
le taureau par les cornes,
pour défendre
la corrida.
Si on connaît tous
la stratégie
alimentaire de l'Europe,
baptisée "de la fourche
à la fourchette",
la vôtre serait
"de la banderille
"à l'assiette".
Ces taureaux,
victimes de mise à mort
anachroniques,
pour vos opposants,
vous les défendez,
et à ce titre, votre plat
du jour n'est pas innocent.
Une gardiane de taureau,
une viande mijotée
dans une sauce au vin rouge.
Une façon de dire que ces bêtes
sont mortes pour la patrie
et la défense d'un terroir,
la Camargue.
Nous ne sommes pas
des anti-viandes
donc nous allons
nous régaler
de cette daube.
Dites-moi
franchement,
la viande d'un taureau stressé,
mort dans la poussière,
a-t-elle pour vous
plus de sens et de goût
que celle d'un taureau,
sorti d'un abattoir ?
-Je tiens à saluer le travail
des éleveurs de taureaux
qui ont permis
que la viande de taureau
soit la première AOP
de viande bovine en France.
Ca, c'est le fruit
d'un long travail,
c'était en 1996,
si je ne dis pas de sottises.
Le taureau de Camargue,
en fait,
n'existe,
et toutes ses exploitations
extensives,
que si la finitude
est la corrida.
Ces taureaux ne sont pas
victimes,
ils vivent entre 5 et 7 ans
en Camargue.
Sur 1 à 1,5 hectare
par animal.
Ils font l'objet de tous les soins
de la part des manadiers,
qui les chérissent.
Chez nous, le taureau n'est pas
une bête qu'on envoie à l'abattoir.
C'est une bête
qu'on envoie au combat.
Il y a quelque chose de sacré
dans le rapport entre l'homme
et le taureau.
-Vous pensez pas
qu'il y a plus
de souffrance
en corrida qu'à l'abattoir ?
-Je ne parlerai pas de souffrance...
-De souffrance animale ?
-Je me garde de faire
de l'anthropomorphisme.
Nos toreros respectent
les animaux, évidemment.
Les lois de la corrida
ont changé.
Les cheveux sont aussi
caparaçonnés et protégés.
Je comprends...
-Le taureau meurt.
La finitude...
-C'est tout le débat,
quand même.
-Il peut être gracié.
Ce qui m'ennuie, moi,
dans le combat que j'ai mené
pour le maintien de la corrida,
ça a été,
j'allais dire,
l'excès de la méconnaissance
de notre culture,
la méconnaissance
de notre fait agricole.
Il y a un fait agricole
et économique
autour de cela.
Et puis, moi,
je crois profondément
que la France est
un pays de libertés,
et qu'on soit capables
de défendre
nos particularismes.
Ce que j'ai entendu,
ça peut paraître simpliste,
mais ça résume tout l'amour
du peuple et de gens,
que j'ai le privilège de servir,
c'est :
"Laissez-nous tranquilles.
"On ne fait que servir
nos traditions."
-Vous faites du mal
aux taureaux.
-Oui, mais je vois
des enfants, des petits,
dans des hameaux reculés,
de la ville d'Arles,
qui est la ville principale
de la circonscription,
et beaucoup de jeunes,
qu'on dit
"des quartiers",
qui s'en sortent grâce
à la course camarguaise,
grâce aux écoles taurines,
en étant au contact des toreros,
de leurs professeurs,
des taureaux...
Tout ça fait un peuple,
une nation locale,
qui, euh...
Vous savez,
on a été épargnés, heureusement,
pendant les émeutes qui ont eu lieu.
Sur l'entièreté
de mon territoire,
aucun méfait, rien !
-C'est dû
aux cultures...
-Ecoutez.
Le soir, on m'a appelé
pour me dire :
"Monsieur le député,
ne vous rendez pas..."
Au pic des émeutes :
"N'allez pas en circonscription."
C'était les ordres
qu'on recevait.
"Rentrez chez vous."
Je me suis aperçu que c'était
le soir de la Pégoulade à Arles.
Où il y a eu
le pic des émeutes.
Et il y a eu des tentatives
de certains groupuscules
et je crois que de voir
3000 Arlésiens en costume,
de voir les chevaux,
qui étaient présents,
les taureaux
avec les manadiers,
c'est pas quelque chose
qui dissuade
mais il y a sur mon territoire
un réel respect
des uns envers les autres.
Je crois que la corrida participe...
-Un fort attachement
à cette culture.
-Chaque partie
de la population,
d'où qu'elle vienne,
a un profond
respect pour nos traditions,
qui sont fortement
ancrées et vécues.
Il n'y a pas une semaine
sans un évènement,
soit autour du costume,
soit autour des taureaux,
soit autour des chevaux,
c'est un territoire
qui est extrêmement ancré.
Tarascon...
-Ca explique le choix de ce plat.
Vous voulez bien
goûter cette gardiane de taureau ?
Vous nous avez fait le plaisir
de nous en apporter,
et on vous en remercie.
Cette gardiane de taureau,
elle ressemble
à celle que vous mangez ?
-Hmm...
-C'est la première fois
que je mange du taureau.
Vous ne changerez pas d'avis
sur la corrida
mais on peut s'accorder
pour dire que le taureau,
je sais pas
s'il vient d'une corrida,
c'est très parfumé.
-Très parfumé.
La viande est un petit peu
plus dur, peut-être,
moins de tendreté...
-Elle est puissante.
-La viande est puissante.
Ca sent bien le vin.
Pour la précision, pour ceux
qui seraient intéressés,
c'est compliqué
de trouver de la gardiane.
Ca s'appelle Marius,
l'épicerie inspirée.
Ils vendent ça
sous forme de bocaux.
Vous trouvez ça
sur Internet,
ils expédient ça
de façon sécurisée.
Cette gardiane de taureau
vaut le détour.
-Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Elle est très bonne.
Je suis étonné
et agréablement surpris
que vous ayez pu vous
en procurer, à Paris.
-Jean-Pierre a fait
les 400 coups
pour vous en trouver.
-Ca a pas dû être simple.
-A Paris, c'est difficile.
Même les restaurants provençaux
ne font pas de la gardiane.
Elle a été cuisinée,
comme vous l'avez dit,
avec du taureau AOP.
Et du vin aussi...
-Si on dit
que c'est...
Que ça ressemble
à du bourguignon...
C'est ça ?
-C'est le même principe.
-C'est pas critique
par rapport
à la recette de la gardiane ?
-Je serais pas critique,
je suis à moitié bourguignon.
C'est l'un des plats
que je réussis le mieux.
C'est le même principe
de viande mijotée.
Après, la typicité,
elle est
sur les épices
utilisées,
sur le vin local ou non,
utilisé,
et le mode de cuisson.
-Je vais vous en parler.
J'ai des choses à vous dire.
-Trois choses à savoir.
Jean-Pierre ?
-Vous savez pourquoi
ça s'appelle gardiane ?
Elle doit son nom au gardian
des troupeaux élevés
en semi-liberté.
Ceux qu'on appelle les manades.
Je parle sous contrôle
du député du sud.
-Le député que je suis
précise qu'on dit "gardian".
-Donc, ce nom, "gardian",
et les manades.
La fleur naturelle
est sa principale nourriture.
Ce lui donne une saveur
unique et parfumée.
La viande de taureau
est tendre,
goûteuse, légèrement
plus forte que...
-Moins tendre.
-...qu'un boeuf
mais moins puissante
qu'un gibier.
Choisissez bien
un taureau AOP.
Plutôt un morceau
comme le collier.
Ou la joue.
Pour faire la daube.
Pour réussir une gardiane,
il faut faire mariner
la viande la veille
dans un mélange de vin rouge,
vous saurez le choisir,
de vinaigre, de thym,
de romarin,
de laurier,
des écorces d'orange,
de sel, poivre, oignon...
On égoutte,
on fait frire,
et on rajoute la marinade.
On fait cuire longtemps.
-A feu doux, j'imagine ?
-Ca doit mijoter très longtemps.
2-3 heures.
On rajoute,
pas dans cette recette,
mais j'ai regardé,
on peut mettre de l'ail
et des anchois.
-Oui.
Après, ça dépend de là où vous êtes,
sur ce vaste territoire de Camargue.
Il y a à peu près autant
de recettes de gardiane,
qu'il y a de familles.
Chacun l'accommode
en fonction de sa proximité
avec le littoral.
-Et votre recette,
votre truc pour
la réussir ?
-Mon petit truc pour la faire...
Je vais peut-être me faire
arracher les yeux
par les citoyens
de ma circonscription.
Je fais comme dans le boeuf,
je rajoute un carré de chocolat.
-C'est vrai que c'est une astuce.
-C'est pas une révolution.
Ca permet d'ajouter un peu
de liant et de l'amertume.
-Vous mettez aussi beaucoup
de thym et de laurier ?
C'est présent.
On le sent bien.
-Très présent.
-J'ai la chance de vivre
dans un...
Dans un village.
Lors de mes promenades,
lorsque j'ai le temps,
je n'ai qu'à me baisser
pour ramasser
du romarin, du thym,
dans la colline...
C'est assez commode.
J'en mets énormément.
-Vous aimez cuisiner ?
C'est une passion
pour vous ?
-Pas une passion,
un plaisir.
C'est souvent dit,
mais cuisiner,
c'est démontrer aux autres
soit qu'on les respecte
soit qu'on les aime.
Ca me fait toujours plaisir
de me mettre trop rarement
aux fourneaux mais...
J'aime énormément ça.
Mon problème :
les quantités.
Si on est 4, les gens pensent
qu'on va être 10 à table.
-Vous faites
en grande quantité ?
-Enormément.
-Famille nombreuse ?
-Des souvenirs d'enfance
d'une grand-mère
pied-noir oranaise.
-Généreuse ?
-Elle partait du principe
qu'on se régalait, elle le disait.
On se prenait une louche
dans l'assiette.
Quand on revenait
des vacances d'été...
J'avais tendance à être
bouboule, plus jeune.
encore plus rondouillard.
-Si c'est de la daube,
pas de problème, c'est très bon,
réchauffé 2-3 jours après.
C'est pas un problème.
Pour d'autres plats,
plus compliqué.
-Pareil que d'autres recettes
de famille...
-C'est quoi, vos plats ?
Qu'aimez-vous cuisiner ?
-J'aime beaucoup
cuisiner
la daube provençale,
parce que j'adore
le goût...
-Pas le taureau ? Le boeuf ?
-Oui, le boeuf.
Le taureau, ça m'arrive.
J'aime faire la blanquette.
J'aime faire des recettes
un peu plus typiques.
Ca, c'est mon éducation
du côté...
Du côté de maman.
J'aime faire les tajines,
j'aime faire la coca,
la frita, aussi...
C'est des recettes
qui sont d'inspiration espagnole
mais qui sont nées en Algérie.
Et voilà, j'aime beaucoup...
Mais j'ai peu de temps
pour cuisiner.
La dernière fois,
c'était à Noël
avec la famille.
-Le sud vous a inspiré ?
Le sud où vous êtes,
maintenant, Arles.
-J'étais déjà un petit peu...
J'étais déjà un petit peu,
j'allais dire, conditionné,
par cette cuisine méditerranéenne,
qui n'a pas été une découverte.
Toute n'est pas découverte.
Mais oui, ça m'inspire.
Par exemple,
j'aime faire des choses,
maintenant,
qui sont un peu plus typiques
de la région arlésienne.
Je me suis acheté un livre,
tiens, la semaine dernière,
sur la cuisine camarguaise.
Je découvre des recettes.
-Vous aimez bien essayer
de nouvelles recettes ?
-J'aime bien acheter
des petits livrets
et sortir
de ma zone de confort.
-A part la daube
et le taureau,
c'est quoi, en Camargue ?
-Les tellines, par exemple.
-Délicieux,
ça, les tellines.
-Très, très bon.
-Tout le monde ne connaît pas...
-Ce sont des petits coquillages,
qui sont faits,
généralement,
en persillade...
Et voilà, qu'on mange...
-C'est très local, ça.
On en mange pas,
à Paris.
-Avec un peu de persil.
Vous nous avez parlé
que de plats à la viande,
vous aimez aussi le poisson.
Vous êtes tout près de la mer.
Des poissons grillés ?
Vous le cuisinez ?
-J'aime bien
les rougets en nage.
-Alors, c'est quoi, ça,
les rougets ?
-Des rougets dans un petit bouillon,
avec de la crème fraîche.
Euh...
-Pas trop d'arêtes ?
-Demandez à ce qu'on les enlève.
Rires
J'aime les fruits de mer aussi.
Alors, vous allez dire...
J'aime les faire
dans les paellas.
Ca m'arrive d'en faire.
Euh, voilà...
C'est-à-dire...
Des crevettes,
des choses comme ça.
Je suis plus fan des crustacés
que je le suis du poisson.
Voilà.
-Vous êtes un peu
conservateur,
en matière de cuisine ?
-Je crois que je suis français.
Vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ?
Donc, je crois que oui.
Conservateur,
je ne sais pas...
-Vous faites du couscous,
ou du tajine...
-Le couscous,
c'est le plat préféré
des Français, donc...
C'est rentré
dans le patrimoine culinaire.
Je crois qu'on a la chance
d'être un pays qui a accueilli
différentes vagues
de population, euh...
C'est lié à notre histoire.
Ces plats, les gens...
C'est la noblesse de la cuisine,
c'est qu'à un moment,
le plébiscite fait
qu'un plat qui peut paraître
exotique ou exogène,
rentre dans le patrimoine
culinaire français.
La France est grande.
C'est la seconde surface
maritime internationale.
On a moult îles
qui ont, elles-mêmes,
de l'influence
chinoise, indienne,
créoles...
-Vous allez chercher
du côté de ces cuisines ?
L'Asie ? L'Amérique du sud ?
-Je vais dire non.
J'ai une de mes cousines
qui a épousé
un médecin antillais.
La dernière cuisine qui, moi,
m'a surpris le palais,
ça a été de manger un cabri
fait au curry,
qu'il avait préparé.
Oui.
C'était aussi encore
une influence qui peut
se faire ailleurs,
sur d'autres îles,
en Guyane française.
Ca a surpris mes papilles.
Ouais, on va dire
que je suis un peu...
Pas chauvin mais...
-La cuisine
japonaise,
thaïlandaise...
Tout ça est à la mode.
-J'ai un tropisme
pour la cuisine asiatique
en général.
Et j'ai un vrai tropisme
pour la cuisine libanaise.
-Les mezzes ?
-Entre autres.
-Une des meilleures cuisines
du Moyen-Orient.
-Justement avant l'émission,
vous me disiez peu manger.
Vous avez l'air gourmand
sur le papier
mais êtes-vous un mangeur ?
Vous êtes prêt à faire
des kilomètres pour trouver
un boui-boui
ou un restaurant ?
A vous écouter,
vous ne mangez pas grand-chose.
-Vous êtes en train de dévoiler
une conversation qu'on a eue
tout à l'heure.
Effectivement...
-C'était du off !
Du off.
-Je ne prends pas
de petit-déjeuner...
-Jeûne intermittent.
Très bien.
-C'est un choix ?
-Non, je crois que c'est
une très mauvaise habitude.
Je ne prends pas de petit-déjeuner.
-Très bon,
selon les nutritionnistes.
-Je ne déjeune pas.
Pardon.
Non, rarement.
Et en fait...
-Vous n'avez pas faim ?
-Non, et pourtant,
les amis,
quand je vais chez eux...
Un ami me l'a dit
récemment :
"Il vaut mieux t'avoir en photo
qu'à table."
Je dévorais.
-Vous ne mangez
ni le matin
ni à midi,
donc le soir...
-Je suis gourmand mais si,
et c'est pas bien,
il faut pas suivre
cet exemple,
si je saute des repas,
c'est quelque chose
qui ne me gêne pas.
-Vous ne déjeunez jamais ?
Vous n'avez qu'un repas
quotidien ?
-Ouais.
-Le soir ?
-A une heure précise ?
Avec vos horaires...
-C'est le soir...
Comme je rentre très tard...
Je suis très présent
en circonscription.
Un repas, c'est un peu...
Ca va être, et c'est pas du tout
de la caricature,
du saucisson de taureau,
avec un morceau de pain,
un morceau de fromage de chèvre
et un verre de vin.
-Vous vous sentez en forme ?
A nous décrire votre menu,
votre quotidien,
c'est pas équilibré.
Vous ressentez pas
de carence ?
-Le matin, je me fais un cocktail
de fruits, j'en mange plein.
J'imagine qu'ils font le boulot.
J'ose le croire.
-Ca vous donne
des vitamines,
pour toute la journée ?
-J'imagine.
Mais après, je suis quelqu'un
qui suis très laborieux,
qui suis très concentré,
et j'ai, euh...
J'ai toujours...
Je cours pas après le temps,
mais j'ai toujours ce souci
d'être présent
et d'être là,
et je me dis,
et c'est souvent la mine
de mes collaborateurs,
l'un ou l'autre
qui m'accompagne...
Quand on voit
qu'à l'heure du déjeuner,
on voit qu'on enclenche
sur une autre série...
Maintenant, je réalise
qu'ils doivent prendre
une heure pour déjeuner,
c'est leurs habitudes,
et ils y ont droit.
Mais à chaque fois,
je leur dis :
"On se retrouve dans une heure,
moi, entre temps, je fais ça !"
Dans ma tête, naturellement,
ça me vient pas de me dire
qu'à midi ou 13h,
il faut déjeuner,
ou qu'à 19h ou 20h,
il faut aller au restaurant...
-Et il n'y a pas toujours
quelque chose à grignoter !
En province...
-Pour se faire plaisir.
-Il y a toujours...
-Vous avez de quoi tenir le coup ?
-Les gens savent
comment je marche.
Ils ont pris l'habitude,
en me suivant sur les réseaux,
de voir ce rythme
effréné,
d'un évènement à l'autre.
Ils ne comprenaient pas
que je ne reste pas.
Si c'est une invitation formelle,
dans ce cas,
je reste.
La semaine dernière,
j'étais à une manifestation
associative de rapatriés
et de Harkis,
qui organisaient
un grand couscous.
J'ai compris qu'ils avaient compris
que je resterai pas à table
mais je suis reparti
avec deux plats
de couscous de la manifestation.
-Vous les avez
congelés, peut-être ?
-C'était à midi.
J'ai passé la journée
sur le terrain.
Ca embaumait
le couscous,
c'était délicieux.
-On peut se vexer,
quand on refuse...
-Comme je vous expliquais...
Comme je veux pouvoir répondre
aux rendez-vous...
-Ils se formalisent pas.
-Ils ont compris la fréquence.
Je ne passe pas en coup de vent.
Je reste 1 ou 2 heures
à chaque événement.
Je ne reste pas 15 minutes
pour serrer des mains.
J'aime discuter
et qu'on me tienne au courant.
Maintenant,
ils comprennent que j'ai pas
forcément l'après-midi...
Ca m'est arrivé à Arles,
dimanche dernier.
Une association traditionnelle
m'a invité
parce qu'ils faisaient
leur déjeuner.
J'avais bien précisé
sur Messenger :
"Je suis ravi
de votre invitation
"mais je viendrai partager un soda
avec vous, et après, je me sauve."
-Est-ce que le RN
défend le localisme,
dans sa politique ?
Est-ce que vous,
à votre niveau,
vous faites aussi...
Vous consommez local ?
Vous faites attention à ça ?
-Alors, je consomme...
Depuis que je suis élu,
je mets un point d'honneur
à presque tout acheter
dans ma circonscription.
Que ce soit la viande,
les légumes,
ou les produits préparés.
-Qui viennent
de la circonscription ?
-Fromage, saucisson...
Alors, je les achète...
Si, je...
Je viens de voir que j'avais
un stock de miel invraisemblable
car on fait beaucoup de miel
dans les Alpilles
et une partie de la Camargue.
J'ai quand même tendance...
Mais c'est bien.
J'imagine que,
sans prétention,
j'assure la promotion
du territoire...
Par exemple, tous les cadeaux
que je fais pour Noël,
ou pour les anniversaires,
sont, j'allais dire,
alimentaires.
Je n'offre que des paniers.
Je le remplis d'huile d'olive
de ma circonscription,
de fromages qui se gardent,
de miel, de vin,
car on en fait...
-Meilleur cadeau pour Jean-Pierre.
-C'est un pays de cocagne !
Vous avez de l'huile d'olive,
des fruits,
des amandes...
Des légumes...
Les meilleures tomates,
les meilleurs courgettes,
les aubergines...
-Une vraie tradition agricole.
-Le poisson, la viande...
Pas besoin de se déplacer !
-On a la chance d'avoir
encore des pêcheurs
à Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer,
mais c'est une terre
bénie des dieux.
Les Alpilles, la Camargue,
la Montagnette,
qui sont sur mon territoire.
Moi, je suis...
Je vais vous dire...
Pour moi,
et c'est pas de la flagornerie,
un matin, il y a pas très longtemps,
c'était avant les fêtes,
je suis allé rabattre du bétail,
justement des taureaux,
avec des manadiers à cheval.
Les gars vous tapent
dans le dos,
vous tutoient,
vous rudoient, même.
Et je me suis senti,
en traversant
et en galopant,
et en étant
avec eux
dans ces paysages
de Camargue,
je me suis senti...
C'est rare
dans la vie.
Je me suis
senti aligné,
à ma place,
et...
Chanceux.
Voire privilégié.
La beauté...
-Une belle circonscription.
-Je lève la tête...
J'essayais de discipliner
le cheval qu'on m'avait confié,
il était pas tendre
avec moi,
et j'ai vu un vol
de flamands roses
dans ce ciel gris,
le soleil se levait...
Je me suis dit :
"Mais, en fait,
tu as une chance folle..."
Mais cette chance,
il faut s'en montrer digne.
Si les gens sont accueillants,
ils vous attendent,
et c'est normal,
au tournant.
-Vous êtes présent
dans la circonscription.
C'est pour ça
que vous vouliez
un plat politiquement,
peut-être, correct.
Avec du riz de Camargue,
on va y revenir.
Et avec un vin
qui est du coin.
C'est le domaine Attilon.
Région Provence,
en appellation IGP
Pays des Bouches-du-Rhône,
Terre de Camargue.
Un terroir
argilo-calcaire et limoneux,
un vin de couleur rouge,
un cépage pinot noir,
un millésime 2020.
Et il a des arômes de cerise
et de framboise, assez épicés.
C'est un vin un peu puissant
qui se marie très bien
avec la gardiane.
Vous le connaissez bien.
-C'est un vin...
C'est un vin
que je connaissais déjà
avant d'être élu
député.
Et puis c'est un vin
que j'ai redécouvert...
Alors, là,
vous allez dire
que je suis très conservateur,
je l'ai redécouvert
dans un déjeuner de chasseurs
auquel j'étais invité.
-Chasseurs,
corridas...
Ca fait beaucoup.
-J'avais décrété,
comme d'habitude,
que je boirais pas
en journée.
Ils m'ont convaincu.
Ca aurait été mal vu
de pas partager
le verre de l'amitié,
et je suis reparti
avec une caisse
de ce vin.
Et euh...
C'est un vin
que j'apprécie énormément.
On a une vraie tradition
de vin en Camargue.
Dans les Alpilles, aussi.
Chacun a sa typicité.
Ces vins ont...
Ils méritent
d'être connus et reconnus.
Les vignerons ont fait un travail
sur la qualité des vins,
sur les 20 dernières années.
Maintenant,
il n'est pas rare de voir des vins
qui sont primés dans des concours
agricoles ou généraux.
Qui plus,
des vins des Bouches-du-Rhône
et de Camargue
et des Alpilles.
Je trouve que le travail
que les viticulteurs font
est quelque chose de magnifique,
avec la vigne,
parce que,
ce qu'on a
dans un verre,
c'est le fruit
de leur travail,
mais c'est aussi
ce que la terre,
les éléments,
aussi par moment
l'eau salée,
veut bien vous donner
à extraire...
-Tout ce terroir
qu'on retrouve
dans ce vin.
Vous m'avez l'air
de vous y connaître.
On va voir ça.
C'est le Quiz.
-Amateur de corrida
et de gardiane,
vous savez que dans le taureau,
tout est bon.
Y compris la queue,
et même les parties
intimes.
Pas de tabou en cuisine !
Pourriez-vous me dire
si ces affirmations
sont vraies ou fausses.
Il lit l'affirmation A.
...
-Je dirais faux.
-Non, vrai !
Rires
-Visiblement, c'est tabou.
Ou alors ça peut amener
à des comparaisons douteuses.
On dit des "animelles",
des "amourettes",
ou des "rognons".
Il lit l'affirmation B.
-Faux.
-Vrai !
-Ah, bah, décidément...
Il lit l'affirmation C.
...
"Joyeuses" est un autre nom,
pour désigner les animelles.
Est-ce vrai que ça célébrait
la cuisine des rognons de coq ?
-Quitte à avoir tout faux,
je ne crois pas.
-C'est faux.
Des rognons de mouton.
-Là, vous avez bon.
Il lit l'affirmation D.
...
-Les bouchées à la reine sont
arrivées avec Marie Leszczynska,
l'épouse de Louis XV.
Je ne sais pas
si le terme est juste.
-Bravo,
parce qu'effectivement,
c'est l'épouse
du roi Louis XV,
qui faisait
des bouchées à la reine
avec des rognons de coq
pour doper
les performances sexuelles du roi.
-Bravo. Deuxième Quiz.
Vous avez sans doute bu
de l'Orangina,
un soda dont la fabrication s'est
longtemps faite à Vitrolles.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
sont vraies ou fausses.
C'est un pied-noir,
Jean-Claude Beton,
qui fonde Orangina
dans la ville de Boufarik,
en Algérie, en 1951.
-Vrai.
-Bravo.
Vous deviez être au courant.
L'affirmation B.
-Je dirais vrai.
-Faux.
Jus de citron,
pamplemousse et mandarine.
Tout ça dans la bouteille
d'Orangina. En 1972,
un clip célèbre
avec un slogan d'Orangina,
"Il faut renverser la bouteille
"pour bien mélanger
la pulpe d'orange."
Est-ce que c'est vrai ou faux ?
-C'est pas "Secouez-moi" ?
-Oui, c'était faux.
-Il faut secouer la bouteille,
et pas la remuer.
-Affirmation D.
-Il me semble.
-Alors, non. On en trouve.
Ca a été lancé en 1983.
-Malgré Coca Cola.
Il y a de l'Orangina
aux Etats-Unis.
"Secouez-moi",
on le connaît tous,
ce clip,
quand on est boomer.
-C'est la génération.
-Le slogan, ils l'ont
fait perdurer il y a pas si...
Il y a de la pulpe
dans l'Orangina.
-Le talent
de cette marque, ça a été
de renverser la table par l'image,
en s'adjoignant le talent
de grands réalisateurs.
-Et c'est la forme
de cette bouteille toute ronde,
qui interpelle,
qui n'a pas changé
depuis toujours.
C'est autour de la table
que se nouent
les histoires,
les deals politiques,
que se fait l'histoire.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
Alors, on vous a demandé
de vous souvenir
d'une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas.
Vous en avez une ?
-Il n'y a pas très longtemps,
l'été dernier,
j'étais donc
à Tarascon,
une des principales villes
de ma circonscription.
Il y avait un spectacle,
j'ai découvert l'homme,
un spectacle
de Patrick Sébastien
à grande échelle.
Le maire de Tarascon avait fait
une table
avec l'ensemble des élus.
Il y a des tendances politiques
qui sont différentes.
M. le maire m'avait fait l'honneur
de me mettre à sa droite.
En face de moi,
j'avais Patrick de Carolis,
le maire d'Arles.
D'autres élus étaient là.
Patrick Sébastien
fait son show, l'atmosphère se...
Voilà,
tout le monde commence
à tourner les serviettes.
J'ai trouvé à drôle,
j'ai voulu que mon mandat
soit sous le signe de la concorde.
Je ne veux pas
d'affrontement entre mes maires
et moi.
On sert notre territoire,
chacun à sa façon,
mais de façon commune.
Et à un moment, l'animateur,
Patrick Sébastien, dit,
lance à la cantonade :
"Faites un bisou,
faites un bisou à votre voisin."
Vous allez être déçus,
il n'y a pas de deal,
mais tout le monde
s'est claqué
la bise
en étant surpris,
mais tellement pris
dans l'ambiance que...
Certaines rigidités
se sont assouplies,
et j'ai trouvé ça...
Je me suis dit
que c'était une belle image,
qui pouvait paraître triviale...
C'était improbable,
lorsque j'ai été élu,
qu'il y ait cette bonne entente.
-Vous pensiez qu'il y allait avoir
de l'animosité ?
-Pas vraiment, je pensais
que comme nouveau de la bande,
nouveauté dans le paysage
politique,
il y avait donc des attentes,
peut-être...
Peut-être des inquiétudes,
je ne sais pas.
Beaucoup disaient des gentillesses
derrière mon dos
sans me connaître.
Et je me suis dit :
"Là, on est à un an et demi
du mandat",
me parlant à moi-même,
"tu as réussi ça."
On est capables
de se mettre autour d'une table,
il n'y a pas d'acrimonie,
je ne mêle pas de leurs histoires,
même si j'en suis au courant,
je ne juge pas leur...
Leurs réflexions,
leurs réalisations,
je me l'interdis.
Je respecte trop leur travail.
Mais on peut arriver,
bien que les étiquettes
ne soient pas les mêmes,
à un moment, à arriver,
non pas à... Je ne vais pas
délirer sur l'état de grâce,
mais à un instant de respect mutuel
où chacun,
quand on travaille sérieusement,
est détendu avec l'autre,
dépose les armes.
Et ce moment-là de fête et de liesse
avec cet animateur...
J'ai été surpris de voir le maire
de Tarascon me faire un bisou,
de devoir en rendre un,
voilà, mais...
J'ai finalement...
Je me suis dit, parce qu'on est
observé par nos concitoyens,
et je me suis dit :
"Est-ce que c'est pas..
"Est-ce que c'est pas donner
un signe
"que les choses peuvent se passer
agréablement,
"qu'on ne s'écharpe pas ?"
-On va passer à la galette,
on est en janvier,
sans transition.
C'est une tradition.
Là, on aurait pu faire
une petite transition.
On déguste
la traditionnelle galette
à la frangipane.
Il existe d'autres variantes,
c'est le dessous des plats.
La monarchie est révolue,
mais on reste
attaché à la couronne.
Pour devenir roi ou reine,
il faut tomber
sur la fève,
logée dans la galette.
Pour les boulangers,
c'est le rush
après Noël,
les Français en raffolent.
Marco Paumier, Marion Devauchelle.
-Star du mois de janvier,
elle est partout :
la galette de rois.
Son succès est incontestable.
-C'est bon, la galette.
-C'est une tradition familiale
depuis...
Un certain nombre d'années,
vous n'étiez pas jeune.
J'ai une petite collection
de fèves.
-Dans cette boulangerie,
on en produit
entre 80 et 100 par jour,
2000 sur le mois de janvier.
Ici, le roi de la galette,
c'est Vincent Salur,
et il y en a pour tous les goûts.
-La spécialité,
c'est la galette 100 % pistache.
On prend des pistaches de Turquie
et d'Iran, on fait un mélange.
On fait aussi
à la pomme, assez classique.
-Mais la plus populaire reste
la galette frangipane.
Tout se joue
au gramme près.
Ne comptez pas sur notre chef
pour vous révéler
les quantités exactes.
C'est un secret bien gardé.
-C'est une recette qui...
Qui date
d'il y a 17 ans.
C'est mon maître d'apprentissage
qui m'a transmis son savoir-faire.
-3 jours, c'est le temps qu'il faut
à Vincent Salur et ses équipes
pour confectionner cette galette.
Première étape, la pâte.
Sa fabrication est longue.
Pétrir la pâte,
24 heures de repos au frigo
avant d'incorporer le beurre,
puis retour au frais
pendant 24 heures.
-Plus on laisse dans le frigo,
plus il y aura de l'arôme.
La pâte va fermenter.
-Après la mise en disque,
l'heure de garnir la galette,
avec la fameuse frangipane.
Du sucre, encore du beurre,
des oeufs
et de la poudre d'amande
venue de Californie.
-En Californie,
elle est très riche en gras.
C'est ce qui donne le goût.
-La touche du chef,
du rhum pâtissier,
sans oublier...
-Une fève en forme de macaron.
-Encore une heure de cuisson
au four
et notre galette est prête.
Reste un hic pour beaucoup
d'entre vous, le prix :
5 euros la part
dans cette boulangerie,
30 euros pour 6 personnes.
-Les gens
disent que les galettes
en boulangerie sont chères,
mais on met 3 jours
pour faire la pâte.
En boulangerie, on aura
une qualité de matière première
plus qualitative. On achète
chez le producteur.
-Un savoir-faire coûteux
aux enjeux importants
pour Vincent Salur :
en janvier, la galette, c'est 50 %
de son chiffre d'affaires.
Près de 10 %
sur l'ensemble de l'année.
-Est-ce que vous faites partie
de ces Français
qui sont fans de la galette ?
-Oui, je fais partie
de cette catégorie de personnes
qui achètent, pendant l'Epiphanie,
des galettes des rois
à la frangipane
et qui les congèlent
pour en avoir sous la main.
-Vous en avez au congélateur ?
-Oui.
-Vous la cuisinez pas ?
-Je l'ai fait.
-Pas la pâte feuilletée ?
Pas la pâte feuilletée ?
-Non, je l'avais achetée.
-Vous adorez la frangipane ?
-Oui, j'adore ça.
-Dans le sud, c'est pas
la traditionnelle ?
C'est pas la couronne des rois ?
-C'est une brioche ?
-La couronne des rois,
dans ma partie du sud,
c'est très joli,
on appelle cette couronne des rois,
cette brioche, un royaume.
-Vous préférez
quand même la frangipane ?
-La frangipane, j'allais dire,
pour le goûter,
parce que je grignote le dimanche
quand je suis à la maison,
et puis le royaume,
donc la brioche,
j'aime bien... Je suis quelqu'un
d'assez régressif,
et j'aime bien la tremper
dans le lait.
-Le petit-déjeuner du dimanche,
alors !
-Dans le sud,
il y a une guerre des galettes ?
La galette, la brioche,
votre royaume ?
A Paris, on voit pas
de brioche du sud.
-Non, c'est très typique,
c'est très...
On doit la trouver
à partir de la Drôme provençale
jusqu'à Nice,
on va balayer la région
en passant par chez moi.
Mais non, il n'y a pas de guerre.
Vous trouvez à parts égales
des royaumes, des couronnes
et des galettes.
-On voit de plus en plus
de variantes.
Il y en au chocolat, dans le sujet,
à la pistache...
Vous aimez ces variantes
ou vous êtes attaché...
-Je vais reprendre le terme
que vous avez dit,
je suis assez conservateur.
J'en ai un peu marre
qu'on change l'origine
des recettes.
Et peut-être que c'est une part
d'enfance qui veut pas partir,
mais je trouve dommage
qu'on réinvente une recette
qui existe
depuis le Moyen Age.
-Est-ce que c'est pas
le progrès de retravailler
une recette ?
-A la pistache, je sais pas
si c'est du progrès
dans le cadre de la science !
-Certains redoutent,
on a vu chocolat-pomme,
des pâtissiers qui déclinent
des gâteaux en galette,
comme l'Ispahan.
Les puristes comme vous,
les conservateurs,
ont la trouille
qu'on ait des gens
qui la revisitent
sous forme de carré,
sous forme de pavé.
On a vu que certains transformaient
les Paris-Brest, les éclairs.
Ca peut arriver, ou bien
elle résistera à ces folies ?
-Je pense que ça résistera,
et ça n'empêche pas l'originalité
ou l'interprétation.
Mais c'est tellement beau,
le symbole de cette galette.
Il y a l'aspect spirituel,
ce qu'elle fête,
mais c'est tellement joli.
Je crois que c'est sensé...
C'est une tradition romaine
qui représente
un soleil,
l'allongement des jours.
On accole cette tradition
aux Rois mages,
mais la symbolique est belle,
si on s'attarde dessus,
de ce...
De cette préparation à base
de beaucoup de beurre et d'amandes.
Ca représente le soleil,
je trouve
que c'est joli.
Ca n'empêche pas
une interprétation.
Je leur souhaite beaucoup de succès.
-Vous trouvez
qu'elle est chère.
On a entendu cet artisan
qui dit que la matière première
est chère.
Ca prend du temps pour la faire.
-Il y a un savoir-faire.
Nos commerçants,
notamment les boulangers,
ont pris en plein visage
la hausse de l'électricité.
C'est l'affaire des chèques,
du "quoi qu'il en coûte".
Il y a un savoir-faire,
une main d'oeuvre.
Je comprends que ça puisse
surprendre, choquer.
J'espère que les gens
qui ont les moyens de payer
30 euros une galette,
chez moi, c'est plus 20 euros,
le font, pour soutenir
leurs artisans boulangers.
-Vous êtes pour la politique
du chèque ? Il faudrait continuer
à approvisionner ?
-Je crois
que si on pouvait leur permettre
de payer leurs factures
et si on ne les assommait pas,
s'ils ne devaient pas éteindre...
Imaginez qu'un boulanger,
s'il éteint un four,
c'est des heures et des heures
à mettre en chauffe,
à tirer
sur des réseaux électriques.
Si la France revenait
à la raison
concernant les prix
de l'électricité,
ça pourrait
être une piste.
Après, je n'ai pas de jugement
sur...
Ceux d'entre nous qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix
que de se tourner
vers le traditionnel.
Tout le monde a quand même
le droit de tirer les rois,
de fêter la tradition
quels que soient ses moyens.
Je comprends qu'on arrive,
dans des villes,
à des prix qui frôlent,
qui tutoient
les 30 euros,
parce qu'il y a la main d'oeuvre.
Il y a plusieurs jours
de préparation pour la pâte
donc, j'allais dire,
c'est le prix
d'un travail bien fait.
Est-ce que je m'en réjouis ?
Non,
mais je crois qu'il faut...
Dans la mesure du possible,
les soutenir.
-On retourne chez vous,
on va parler
du riz. Cet aliment est
en grande partie importé
d'Inde, de Thaïlande.
On en parle
et on met les pieds
dans le plat.
-Brigitte, le Français aime
de plus en plus le riz.
Il en mange 6 kilos par an.
Ce qui est ridicule
par rapport au Birman,
champion du monde,
qui en consomme 170 kilos
par an. Le riz de nos assiettes
est essentiellement importé d'Asie
mais un tiers vient
de la Camargue
et du delta du Rhône,
où on produit
un riz IGP de qualité.
Reportage les pieds dans l'eau
de Clément Pérot,
tourné en automne dernier,
au moment de la récolte.
-On dit du riz
qu'il pousse les pieds
dans l'eau et la tête au soleil.
En France, sa terre d'adoption
était toute trouvée :
la Camargue.
Alain Giraud est riziculteur
dans ce coin du sud si singulier,
où pousse 95 % du riz français.
-Pour le riz,
il faut des sols plats.
La Camargue est un territoire
assez plat, c'est beaucoup
plus facile à niveler
que de faire du riz en montagne
ou comme on voit beaucoup en Asie.
Nous avons les deux bras du Rhône
qui alimentent en eau douce.
Un grand volume d'eau arrive.
Le riz nécessite, dans sa culture,
beaucoup d'eau.
-Les champs sont mis en eau
au printemps pour 150 jours,
puis à sécher quelques semaines
avant la récolte automnale,
qui a lieu ce jour-là
sur cette parcelle.
Le riz se ramasse
avec une moissonneuse-batteuse
équipée de chenilles, pour avancer
dans la terre humide.
Les plantes sont comme peignées
par la machine.
Elle en extrait les grains
encore recouvert par leur enveloppe
naturelle, la balle.
-Ca, c'est ce que ramasse
le riziculteur.
Après, le rizier va faire
les opérations pour le blanchir.
-Cette année,
la récolte est bonne.
Les fortes chaleurs sont favorables
à la fécondation du riz.
La filière
a le potentiel pour se développer.
-On produit
à peu près 13 000 hectares de riz,
ce qui fait à peu près
70 000 tonnes de riz,
ce qui couvre à peine
20 % de nos besoins en France.
L'idée, ce serait
de revenir à une souveraineté
alimentaire
pour la France.
Ce serait très intéressant.
-Plus que la quantité,
le riz made in France se distingue
par sa qualité.
Le chef Roger Merlin nous donne
sa recette du risotto
vers Camargue.
-Echalote, ail.
Je mets le riz dedans.
C'est le riz spécial pour risotto,
rond.
On va attendre
que le vin soit absorbé
pour mettre le bouillon.
Du romarin, du thym,
toutes les herbes que j'ai.
Les épluchures de légumes,
au lieu de les jeter,
je fais un bouillon.
J'en mets une ou deux cuillères,
je vais remuer.
-En fin de cuisson,
le chef ajoute du parmesan
et de la crème de riz.
Ce risotto de la terre est
accompagnés de légumes croquants,
saucisse de taureau fumée,
carpaccio
et chorizo de taureau.
-On est vraiment
dans le terroir de Camargue,
des produits,
des recette simples.
-Blanc, noir, rouge, complet :
une grande diversité
de riz est produite
en Camargue.
-On l'a dit,
le riz camarguais
fournit 30 % de la consommation
française, à peine.
Les riziculteurs peuvent
faire du riz
en grande quantité.
Pourquoi on n'essaye pas
de développer cette culture
dans ce delta et en Camargue ?
Il y a des réticences,
des obstacles ?
-Non, ils essayent
de les développer.
Après, on est confronté aussi
à une multiplicité
de territoire,
et les exploitations,
si elles peuvent être extensibles,
encore faut-il acheter
les terres disponibles
à la culture
pour pouvoir augmenter
cette production.
Je sais qu'ils y travaillent
beaucoup.
-Il y a des questions
de protection
de la biodiversité ? Il n'y a pas
un duel entre la Camargue
et le riz ?
-Non, il n'y a pas duel.
La Camargue est un parc naturel
régional.
Je me suis battu, et notamment
avec l'alerte des producteurs
de riz,
des éleveurs de taureau
et de chevaux,
pour qu'on n'ait pas le label
Parc national,
ce qui aurait été dramatique.
Donc il y a effectivement
une imprégnation
entre deux visions de l'écologie
et du développement du territoire.
La Camargue,
c'est comme la Vénétie,
c'est une création humaine.
Les chantres de l'écologie
oublient que c'est l'homme
qui a décidé de créer
une interaction
entre des éléments
comme l'eau douce, de mer,
et la terre,
qui est particulière chez nous.
Tout ça est le fruit de la main
de l'homme.
Ils travaillent
à augmenter cette filière-là.
J'avais insisté l'an passé,
j'avais été déçu
au Salon de l'agriculture
de voir que la Camargue était
très peu représentée.
Cette année...
-Il pourrait y avoir
une souveraineté alimentaire
dans le riz ?
On en importe près de 80 %.
-Oui, 70 %.
On ne peut pas avoir
de souveraineté,
mais augmenter de 10 à 20 %,
pour moi, ça serait pas...
Ca serait pas lunaire,
ça serait pas de l'ordre
de l'imagination.
Mais encore faut-il
qu'on puisse...
Tout à l'heure, je parlais
de la captation de terrains
et de la possibilité de grandir.
Ca devient de plus en plus
compliqué.
Sur mon territoire,
j'ai été alerté
sur notamment les successions
en domaine agricole,
qui vont parceller,
parce que les héritiers ne vont pas
pouvoir garder
leurs grands domaines.
Les héritiers qui ne sont pas
agriculteurs
n'ont pas vocation
à garder cette terre particulière,
qui coûte très cher.
Ca peut aussi être la cause...
Celui qui en a le plus
sous le pied peut capter
ces terrains.
-Il y a des étrangers qui peuvent,
comme on achète des vins,
des vins de Bordeaux...
Des Chinois qui pourraient venir
nous acheter ?
-On a de plus en plus
de personnes étrangères
à notre territoire
qui rachètent
des parcelles, des hectares entiers,
et pas des petites zones,
pour, souvent, s'y fixer en termes
de résidence secondaire,
qui ne travaillent pas cette terre
qui est particulière,
et qui, à terme, pourrait mener,
sur une partie de nos territoires,
à la mort de nos paysages
tels que nous les connaissons.
Ce sont des paysages
certes sauvages,
mais qui ne sont pas sauvages
pour faire joli.
Les sabots de taureaux
les travaillent,
les sabots de chevaux...
-L'Etat devrait aider
cette région ?
-Je pense qu'à terme,
on va en avoir besoin.
On a été interrogé,
par le ministère de la Transition
écologique entre autres,
l'année dernière, sur,
spécifiquement,
la gestion de l'eau
et le devenir de la Camargue.
Lorsqu'on voit certaines projections
à 100 ans,
si on ne se dépêche pas d'agir,
une bonne partie sera sous l'eau.
Donc il est temps de se bouger.
100 ans, c'est demain.
Je ne serai plus là,
et personne n'aura souvenir de...
Voilà, je...
Mais le temps que je suis là,
à ma place,
que les acteurs publics sont
à leur place,
je crois qu'il est temps de cesser
de se payer de déclarations
et de vraiment travailler sur :
quelle est...
Que se fixe-t-on à 100 ans
pour ce territoire,
pour qu'on puisse le léguer ?
J'ai aucune démarche égoïste,
je n'ai pas d'enfant
à titre personnel,
ce ne sera pas ma continuité
qui verra le paysage.
-C'est pour sauver le territoire.
-On se bat en plus
pour qu'il soit inscrit à l'Unesco,
pour que cette reconnaissance
permette
une protection. Ca veut dire
des moyens financiers
pour travailler
sur le trait de côte et l'eau.
-C'est un paradoxe,
le réchauffement climatique
est favorable au riz,
à sa fécondation.
-La chaleur permet
d'en cultiver plus.
-Et à un meilleur rendement.
Si les eaux montent,
l'eau douce protège
cet écosystème.
Si les eaux sont trop salées,
il n'y a plus de cultures.
-Les eaux qui montent sont salées.
Le pompage pour avoir de l'eau douce
est compliqué,
il faut avoir la ressource
en eau douce.
Je ne veux pas dire de bêtise,
mais il y a 2 ans,
la situation était caniculaire
et un manadier m'a dit
que deux de ses taureaux
étaient morts
parce que l'eau qui remontait
du sol était salée,
et les bêtes ne l'ont pas
supporté.
-On va passer
au dessert, on a fini le plat :
c'est le péché mignon.
-Avec un dessert totem
de la Botte,
le tiramisu, qui serait
le 2e mot italien
le plus utilisé dans le monde.
"Tiramisu" signifie
"Redonne-moi
"des forces". Il faut du café
pour qu'on soit réveillé.
Vous avez des racines italiennes
pour aimer le tiramisu ?
-Je n'en ai pas,
je suis vice-président du groupe
France-Italie
et j'ai une passion pour l'Italie
que je ne m'explique pas.
-On y mange bien.
-J'ai une passion culturelle,
j'aime parler italien,
j'aime lire en italien,
j'aime regarder les infos
en italien.
J'ai vécu en Italie,
à vrai dire,
et j'ai une passion
pour ce pays. Et en fait,
le tiramisu est une recette
lombarde, d'Italie du nord.
Ca veut dire :
"Tire-moi vers le haut".
-Je crois
que c'est plutôt né à Trévise.
Il peut y avoir après...
Il y a toujours des paternités.
-Quand je vivais en Italie du nord,
d'abord à Milan puis à Venise,
j'avais une "pasticceria",
une pâtisserie à côté de la maison
qui faisait un tiramisu
à se damner.
Et en fait,
je ne mangeais jamais
de sucre, j'ai découvert le goût
du sucre grâce à ce dessert.
-Et vous le préparez chez vous ?
-Oui.
-C'est assez facile à faire.
Là, je reviens aussi,
c'est le traditionnel ?
-Oui, parce que je n'ai rien
contre nos amis...
-Quel biscuit ?
-Le... Les boudoirs.
Les biscuits à la cuillère.
-Ah, savoiardi.
Moi, je préfère pavesini,
les plus plats.
Il y a une bagarre en Italie.
-Pour moi, c'est boudoir.
Les biscuits à la cuillère.
-Goûtez-le pour nous dire.
-Le classique,
parce que je n'ai rien
contre mes collègues nordistes,
ou nos amis belges,
mais les tiramisus aux spéculoos,
pour moi, c'est...
-Une trahison.
-Oui, je trouve que c'est très...
-On en trouve aussi
aux fruits rouges
quand c'est la saison.
-On revisite le tiramisu
-C'est vrai que le traditionnel...
-Je trouve que ça fait partie...
Avec le mascarpone,
la tendreté de la chose,
on a l'impression
de croquer dans un nuage.
C'est ça qui est
assez plaisant.
-Celui-ci
est bon,
mais il manque toujours,
pour nous tirer vers le haut,
de café.
Il ne va pas nous réveiller.
-Il manque de café
et certainement
d'un peu d'amaretto.
Un peu d'alcool !
-On finit toujours
en musique, avec votre choix.
"Largo", Haendel
...
La musique continue,
c'est d'Haendel.
Pourquoi celle-ci ?
-C'est le "Largo",
c'est l'introduction,
il est beaucoup plus beau chanté
lorsque l'alto va
tout en haut,
on dirait qu'il supplie le ciel.
En fait, c'est le Largo de Xerxès",
du roi perse Xerxès,
un roi imaginaire, d'Haendel,
Qui... "Ombra Mai Fu",
c'est une déclaration d'amour
d'un roi de la guerre
à un platane,
qui lui dit : "Je suis si bien
"sous tes frondaisons,
je n'ai plus à affronter
"l'injustice des hommes
et celle du glaive. Protège-moi."
Et les aigus
qui sont... La Bartoli,
Cecilia Bartoli les chante
très bien.
Il y a quelque chose
qui me perce le coeur.
La première fois, c'était
au Théâtre des Champs Elysées,
interprété par un chanteur d'opéra
allemand,
et les larmes ont coulé.
J'ai eu l'impression
d'entendre la voix des anges.
C'était quelque chose qui vous...
Quand cet air est chanté,
moi, ça me transperce le coeur.
J'allais dire,
pas de tristesse,
ce sont des larmes...
A chaque fois, ça m'émeut.
-On finit là-dessus,
si vous le voulez bien.
Merci
d'avoir partagé ce déjeuner
avec nous.
Merci à Chez Françoise,
qui nous accompagne.
Merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis.
Rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle émission.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...